the place won't touch you but I will
[Music]
Los Angeles the City of Angels
more like the city of dirty little
secrets
people pay me to look into the
activities of its finest citizens
I'm a private detective
the name is Philip Marlow
how private are your investigations Mr
Marla what can I do for you I'd like you
to find my lover he disappeared without
saying goodbye
haven't we all
[Music]
what does my daughter want my mother was
in pictures
she must think there's something between
us
[Music]
I hear that you are looking for someone
we're all looking for someone I'll pay
you a thousand if you find him for me
the puzzle has many pieces I don't know
what you're gonna find
I'm going down the rabbit hole I'm not
afraid to take you with me I do like to
think about not being afraid
we should be
they're all in on the conspiracy you'll
keep looking because you can't stop the
police won't touch you but I will
of all the people in Los Angeles who you
do not mess with they're on top of the
list the key to Hollywood is knowing
when your game is up you go in there I'm
coming out alive
I have to ask myself who wins Mr Marlow
I will do everything to put you in jail
[Music]
may all of our secrets
your secret
you'll have to keep those too
[Music]